hello freak bitches if you're a dude and
your best friend is a woman it's it's
it's it's it's suspect it's very suspect
highly suspect yeah yeah unless she's
really unusual well look there are there
are look and I'm not saying that women
and hot women and whoever are I mean
they're fucking they can be great
friends but yeah you all if they're hot
and even if they're not you sometimes
still wanna yeah and that's okay right
you know but guys that do have like a
hot woman that's the best friend that
they're not banging and they pretend now
it's just totally platonic mmm okay yeah
I could never trust that guy unless he
has like an insanely hot wife that that
yeah or or if they used to date yes
that's works yeah that's possible if
they like legitimately have nothing to
do each other anymore right like I have
exes that like I wouldn't want to sleep
with but in their hot you know what I
mean
right it's over yeah it's over but
you're still friends yeah yeah friendly
yeah they're not your best no no no
Shawn no and shit fucking weird that's
weird
well it's weird with anybody pretty like
when a guy is like working an angle and
try really hard to like position himself
as better than you like position himself
as being like different than him every
other guy I'm you know there's a lot of
guys out there doing really negative
things I read this one guy's fucking
Twitter page other day it was amazing it
was just like he might be the ultimate
white knight I don't want to give out
his Twitter page yeah but even he might
be like the greatest if I met him he
probably has almost no blood in his
veins
his blood sugar is probably zero he
probably faints all day long it was so
weak but one of the things he said is he
said he said although I still practice
feminists I still practice feminism I no
longer associate are no longer would you
say advertise myself as a feminist
because I feel like it's up to women to
decide whether
not I'm doing feminism correctly Jesus
Christ so I'll still practice feminism
but I will no longer advertise myself as
a feminist Jesus Christ dad that's I
actually don't even know what to say
about that and then I got started
playing in a rock band in my 20s since I
didn't do much martial arts at all did
you do you practice music before that
like when did you get involved in immune
I was growing up as a kid Bruce Lee and
Alice Cooper we were like my two okay so
that's the glam rock came from the make
up and yeah and late mid 20s I started
playing in a band and I really liked
performing and I did a lot of jumping
and kicking and wearing tight pants and
you know and I liked it was sooo David
Lee Roth so exactly exactly and
somewhere between David Lee Roth and the
New York Dolls I know I'm very drunk
very very fucked up like through the
whole era like we would go and we man
and I told Eddie this story I haven't
told a lot of people this story but
people asked me about it my friends
asked me about it recently but I was
basically on tour so I do that for like
10 12 14 years and we're touring England
in the UK and and like Italy and a few
places like that we did really well over
there and I had a seizure from just
doing so much drugs and drinking so much
and like a bad like you basically I had
been that when I came back the doctor
said the vodka and Red Bull was actually
the biggest component the fact that I
took a lot of speed over the three days
without sleeping let me drink more vodka
redbull but basically as the sugar
leaves your body it goes down and you
get sick and when the alcohol then
leaves your body it draws more sugar and
you have a hypoglycemic seizure so I'm
laying on the couch I felt terrible for
like 10 hours and then all of a sudden
apparently I just yelled something and
people came over and I felt this
electricity shooting down my arms into
my hands and they just locked up and I
rolled back down my eyes rolled in my
head I thought it was ten seconds later
and everyone's looking at me like I just
got knocked out you know and then
apparently it was like a minute or
something and I went back and the doctor
said dude you gotta get your life
together Wow and I started training
martial arts again pretty much that day
and then I trained you know three times
a week then five then
seven then I was doing jujitsu Monday
Wednesday Friday 7:00 a.m. noon and 6:00
p.m. and Tuesday and Thursday noon and
6:00 p.m.
wait a minute you were trained to do two
three times a day every times a day
Monday Wednesday Friday twice a day
Tuesday Thursday for about six months
and then people kind of knew me a little
in Canada like on television doing stuff
I was like a reality show judge and the
network said oh you're gonna fight well
why don't we do a TV show about that Wow
and that kind of loud me I really wanted
to be in the fight world that's what I
love the second I kind of had you know
been not living a crazy lifestyle all I
wanted to do was martial arts and then
real really from that minute on that's
all I kind of did that's all I was
interested in how did you get started
rapping man well let you do you consider
that rap kind of I mean I started off in
spoken-word so I started off just kind
of with no beat spars into hip-hop and
again a lot of people hear spoken word
and think that sounds shit basically in
poetry and that but I was exactly the
same
spoken word has potential right Kamini I
mean what do people like I mean people
love I have a dream yeah I have a dream
as goddamn spoken word I mean Martin
Luther King's I have a dream speech why
always refer to a spoken word rather
than poet or anything else that's the
most literal right and I mean a really
an intricate stand-up set that's like
one piece that's a whole story that's a
spoken word
it's just does that word poetry does
poet does that have a bad connotation
like a pretentious critique belong from
people kind of think yeah obviously I
remember I was at the the Comedy Cellar
in New York and David tells on stage and
he's killing and there's just not a fuck
in the audience and for some reason the
guy took offense to one of Dave's jokes
and says something and and days like
well I'm sorry sir just drop here trying
to do some jokes what do you do for a
living sir you know he's fucking the guy
goes I'm a poet
published and I'll never forget that and
there for a year I was saying that to
people I'm a poet published like
insurance and shit like that I just try
and explain what I do and then just go
with unemployed or self-employed itself
I put poetry or my or my thing let's I
never forget that asshole
I'm the power published and he had like
fashionable clothes on shit you know
just Oh totally lives at home still with
his mom Ava tell doesn't even remember
it but I remember it it wasn't even me
that got heckled fuckheads